ich war ein Leben lang gegen Atomkraft
schlicht weil ich es für
unverantwortlich hielt und halte und
endlichen Generationen nach uns das
ungelöste problemstrahlenden Atommülls
zu hinterlassen Atomkraft war für mich
das Flugzeug das losfliegt ohne das
schon eine Landebahn gebaut werden jetzt
aber ohne russische Energie und mit eh
schon laufenden AKWs Gewichte ich für
mich die Argumente anders finde
zumindest den Weiterbetrieb eh schon
existierender Kraftwerke vertretbar
jedenfalls solange es für die
Energiesicherheit unbedingt nötig ist
Olaf Scholz hat sich im Ampel internen
Streit er macht Wort für ein kurzen
Mittelweg entschieden eine Entscheidung
die einerseits zumindest in diesem
Winter hilft und andererseits den Atom
Müllberg nicht weiter vergrößert den
schon produziert zu haben ist schlimm
genug die stehen sie zur Atomkraft
schreiben Sie es gerne in die Kommentare